Herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 273, wo wir wie Bösezungen behaupten würden, ausnahmsweise mal Digitalisierung konstruktiv gestalten wollen. Also weil ihr, wenn ihr euch nicht nicht in die allzu ferne Vergangenheit zurückdenkt, von nur zwei Sendungen haben wir schon mal drüber gesprochen, was eine Bundestagswahl möglicherweise verändern könnte und haben da aber vor allem darüber gesprochen, was alles schief gelaufen ist. Das soll heute anders werden und Anlass ist, dass der Chaos Computer Club, dem das Chaos Radio ja mehr oder weniger gehört, eine Liste herausgebracht hat, die dazu dienen soll, den geneigten PolitikerInnen zu zeigen, was man besser machen sollte, wenn man ein gutes digitales Leben ermöglichen möchte. Ich möchte zuallererst allerdings einen Gast begrüßen, der in der vor zwei Sendungen auch schon dabei war, nämlich Anna Biselli von Netzpolitik. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück.
Hallo.
Dass du heute hier bist, sagt mir, dass es zumindest Hoffnung gibt, dass es Sinn macht, darüber zu reden, was man besser machen könnte.
Das ganze Auto-Metaphern.
Es fällt langsam auf. Autobahnen in Berlin bauen ist ja auch eher schwierig. Anna, willst du noch zu dieser Geschwindigkeit, die da in den Tag gelegt wird, was sagen?
Ich habe da gar keine Meinung zu, muss ich sagen. Es ist doch was Positives zum Sondierungspapier eingefallen. Ich habe nachgedacht. Was auffällt ist, dass es im Vergleich zu glaube ich allem, was wir von vorher kennen, von den Jahren, nicht so ein absurdes, wir brauchen hier Sicherheit und hier Verschärfung und hier dieses, da steht irgendwie dieser eine Satz drin, es kommt auf mehr präventive Sicherheit an, da denkt man so, was meinen sie damit? Aber ansonsten geht es eigentlich. Also das finde ich tatsächlich auch momentan stimmt mich noch heiter.
Ich würde fast sozusagen schon offiziell gerade einbiegen wollen, aber noch ein konkretes Thema herausgreifen wollen, das ist Bildung. Das ist ja, da gab es ja viel Stress in letzter Zeit und es gab ja diese, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie das konkrete Ding ist, es gab ja diese Bildungsmilliarden, die dann irgendwie versickert sind mit der Digitalkampagne, die Digitalinitiative, und dann war es mit Corona ganz schlimm, was digitale Bildung angeht, also sowohl digitale Kompetenz auszubilden, als auch digitale Infrastruktur am Start zu haben, ist das was, was für euch auch eine Rolle spielt, also Bildung nicht im Sinne von die Ministerien müssen Kompetenz werden, sondern im Großteil der Bevölkerung, oder in der ganzen, in der Zivilgesellschaft, da ist das Wort, in der Zivilgesellschaft muss digitale Bildung verankert werden und das fängt halt ganz, ganz vorne an. Oder ist das oder folgt das dann sowieso logisch aus den anderen Punkten, die wir heute besprochen haben?
Ich glaube andersherum. Die anderen Punkte folgen logisch daraus, dass die Bildung sowohl im digitalen zwingende Fortbild, ich sehe es ja immer wieder hautnah in den aktuellen Entscheidungen, Gerichtsentscheidungen zu den Filesharing-Sachen, wo ganz eindeutig die Richter überfordert sind von den technischen Zusammenhängen und sich dort etwas an die Backe labern lassen. Da ist es sehr wichtig, zwingende Fortbildung bei bestimmten Menschen mit Entscheidungskompetenzen zu haben und mit selber Lehrkompetenzen. Also sowohl Lehrer als auch die Verwaltung als auch Richter sollten zwingend Fortbildung im digitalen nehmen, um dort einfach im Beruf fit zu bleiben. Auf der anderen Seite auch, wenn du auf den Querschnitt der Gesellschaft in Deutschland guckst, sind ja die meisten Menschen von ihrem letzten Bildungserlebnis echt lange entfernt. Das heißt, das siehst du ja an der Ausstattung und am Zustand von Universitäten und Schulen. Es ist ja so, dass die meisten Menschen in Deutschland schon ewig keine Schule mehr von innen gesehen haben. Weder als Eltern noch als Schüler selber, weil so wo ist der Durchschnitt der Bevölkerung wie bei 45 oder so. Das heißt, wenn du das mischst mit einem und mit dem Internet kennen wir uns eh alle nicht aus, dann hast du den perfekten Sturm, um sowohl die Bildungseinrichtungen verkommen zu lassen, als auch die überhaupt gar nicht aus dem Radar zu haben, dass die auch digitale Infrastruktur brauchen. Und da braucht es einmal ein ganz großes Bewusstwertungsprogramm, dass wenn du nicht dort an den Stellen, wo wir den grundsätzlichen Unterbau für zukünftige Generationen, die sich da im Digitalen wie selbstverständlich auch souverän und nicht nur auf die großen Unternehmen hörend aufstellen müssen, wenn du das nicht schon in einer grundsätzlichen Politik verankerst und dort auch diesen Ausbau im digitalen Bildungsanrichtung vorantreibst, dann wirst du da in 20 Jahren wahrscheinlich vor den Scherben unserer Bildungsgesellschaft stehen.
Okay, Anna, hast du irgendwie Bedürfnisse oder was ist am wichtigsten, wenn wir über digitale Bildung in Deutschland reden für die nächste Regierung?
Ich glaube, digitale Bildung hast du halt immer das Ding, niemand würde dir sagen, dass das schlecht ist. Also alle sagen, digitale Bildung, supi, brauchen wir. Und die Frage ist halt, wie man die Zugänglichkeit erreicht. Das heißt, man hat ja jetzt gesagt, okay, es gibt einen Digitalpakt für Zeug, es gibt einen Digitalpakt 2.0 für noch ein bisschen mehr als Zeug, aber wie kommt man denn irgendwie da ran? Das ist ja so ein bisschen breitbandmäßig. Man muss ja irgendwie auch das Geld zugänglich machen und nicht nur irgendwo hinwerfen und sagen, komm, holt es euch, indem ihr irgendwie einen komplizierten Antrag ausfüllt. Ich glaube, mehr habe ich gar nicht.
Ja, ich wollte mich da anschließen. Also ich sehe das auch ein bisschen skeptisch. Ich glaube, wer auch immer mit Lehrerinnen und Lehrern näher zu tun hat in den letzten Jahren, weiß, dass so viele gut gemeinten Ansätze daran schallt haben, dass sie einfach höfungslos überfordert sind und wie man arbeitet, weil es gibt wenig Ressourcen. Der Job wird nach und nach weniger attraktiv gestaltet. Das ist ein Knochenjob. Und dann darüber hinaus auch noch irgendwelche Weiterbildungen und Fortbildungen sich drauf packen, um diesen gesteigerten Ansprüchen, also digitale Bildung, auch als Lehrerin oder Lehrer nachkommen zu können. Ich glaube, das ist eine große Herausforderung und das muss man glaube ich immer mitdenken. Genauso wie Digitalisierung von Behörden und so weiter. Wenn du mit Leuten zu tun hast, die überarbeitet sind, dann musst du halt ganz genau überlegen, wie sowas nachhaltig gemacht wird. Ansonsten, ich kenne mich mit Bildungspolitiken nicht so super gut aus. Ich sehe halt nur, dass in den letzten Monaten, glaube ich für uns alle, ein bisschen klar geworden ist, dass es ein Stück weit scheißegal ist, wie es Kindern geht. Und das finde ich ziemlich fürchterlich so zu sehen. Ich hoffe, dass das bessert und keine Ahnung, das finde ich ziemlich unhaltbar, dass nach wie vor keine, dass Ewigkeiten, keine Filter eingebaut wurden, dass Schulen irgendwie so super vernachlässigt wurden. Ich hoffe, dass das ändert. Was ich spannend fand, in dem, das hat ein bisschen mehr mit meiner Expertise zu tun, in dem Sortierungspapier war das Lebenschancen-BaföG. Das schreckliche System muss dringend reformiert werden. Ich finde aber, dass dieses Thema lebenslanges Lernen darin aufgegriffen wird. Ich glaube, das ist eine spannende Sache, wo ich auf jeden Fall ein Auge darauf haben werde, wie sich das entwickelt. Weil ich glaube, dass, nämlich auf jeden Fall mit so Diversität in der Technologiebranche beschäftigt und glaube, dass so ein BaföG oder Förderung für Leute, die aus allen klassischen Förderungsinstrumenten rausfallen, weil sie zu alt sind, weil sie nicht mehr studieren oder weil das ein Zweitstudium wäre, sowas finde ich grundsätzlich erstmal interessant, weil ich glaube, dass es viele Leute gibt, die eigentlich Lust hätten, so eine Art, in Anführungszeichen, Bruch in ihrer Karriere zu haben. Und das finde ich auf jeden Fall ziemlich spannend, weil wenn wir über digitale Bildung sprechen, denken, stellen wir uns oft auch Kids vor und Grundschulen, Oberschulen. Aber ich glaube, dass es darüber hinaus auch noch vier digitale Bildung geben sollte in allen Facetten. Und das kann entweder eine institutionelle Förderung sein von, okay, häng deinen bisherigen Job an den Nagel, mach zwei Jahre eine Ausbildung und ein Studium für drei, vier, fünf Jahre. Und dann haben wir halt eine neue Fachkraft. Das finde ich grundsätzlich erstmal interessant, weil das auch, soweit ich weiß, auch meiner Erfahrung nach vielen Frauen auch noch mal den Eintritt ermöglichen würde. Aber genau, ich glaube, so dieses Thema lebenslanges Lernen und digitale Bildung muss auch jenseits der Schulen stattfinden in einen Altersgruppen.
Es gibt in der Formulierungsschritte der CCC noch ganz viele Themen, die wir jetzt auch nicht besprochen haben. Da geht es irgendwie noch um autonome Systeme, auch um das Lieblingsthema Breitbandausbau, auch das kam noch in unserer Sprache. Also guckt euch das noch mal genauer an, weil es hier auch um den Überbau ging, um das, was man damit erreichen will. Und damit würde ich auch gerne enden wollen und euch fragen wollen, wenn es jetzt, also nicht eine Utopie, also nicht sozusagen wünscht ihr was, sondern wenn ihr das, was ihr jetzt von dem, was gerade passiert, seht, wenn ihr das den optimistischsten, aber noch realistisch bleibendsten Blick in die Zukunft richtet. Ja, also es geht alles gut, aber es ist halt auch im Rahmen dessen, was in Deutschland so machbar ist. In welcher digitalen Gesellschaft leben wir in vier Jahren? Was für guten Dinge können dabei rauskommen?
Ich bin gerade ein bisschen hin und her. Entschuldigung, Marcus, können wir, bevor wir diese, das ist eine interessante Frage, kann ich zunächst eine andere beantworten. Ich bin ziemlich in ein Patch, wir hatten, da stand eine Frage drin, die ich mir sehr zu Herzen genommen habe und nämlich, was fehlt in dieser Formulierungshilfe? Das fände ich tatsächlich nochmal spannend, die Anwesenden zu fragen. Ich glaube, bei Erdgeist ist es ein bisschen schwierig, du hast da mitgeschrieben. Aber vielleicht auch nochmal, Anna, mir selbst habe ich auch nochmal die Frage gestellt, wenn ich darf, darf ich darauf kurz eingehen? Gut, ein Absatz zum Thema digitale Gewalt. Riesengroßes Thema, das hat auch viel mit Plattformregulierung natürlich zu tun. Wir sprechen viel darüber, dass wir Daten schützen müssen und das hat unmittelbar natürlich auch mit Menschen, das hat oder hat mittelbar mit Menschen auch zu tun. Aber wie schützen wir eigentlich Menschen, die online unterwegs sind? Und dazu gibt es zu wenig Forschung. Das hat ganz klare Auswirkungen auf den nicht-online-Space oder auf den Meet-Space, wie auch immer, auf den analogen Space, überträgt sich in Gewalt. Und es gibt eine enorme Radikalisierung und das Thema muss einfach angegangen werden. Steht sogar in einigen Wahlprogrammen drin. Den Sondierungspapieren hab ich jetzt nicht mehr gefunden, aber das ist ein Absatz, der fehlt mir da drin. Wenn wir überlegen, was muss das Internet, was muss Netzpolitik leisten in den nächsten vier Jahren, dann ist das ein Thema, das steht für mich ganz, ganz weit oben. Es taucht in den Statistiken nicht auf. Es ist aber einfach eine Realität für einen großen Teil der Nutzen, der Internetnutzenden und es muss besser erforscht werden. Es muss da mehr Regulierung ran. Es kann nicht sein, dass wir unglaublich viel Stalkerware noch frei verfügbar haben in den App-Stores und so weiter und so fort. Und da müssen Lösungsansätze her und da müssen wir uns, glaube ich, auch einmischen und mit daran arbeiten.
Das wollte ich auch sagen. Ich habe auch noch eine kleine Liste von den Sachen, die mir fehlen. Ah, sehr gut. Ich unterstütze das einfach. Nee, aber damit auch verbunden. Ich habe mich gefragt, ob es Absicht ist, dass es irgendwie nicht so vorkommt. Das ist eigentlich die ganze Plattformfrage und es ist halt auch super schwer, darauf eine Antwort zu kriegen und ich kenne die Diskussion zu dieser Formulierungshilfe nicht, aber wenn es sie gegeben hätte, hätte ich sie mir hart vorgestellt. Aber das fehlt halt und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen...
Kannst du kurz genau sagen, was du mit Plattformfrage meinst?
Dieses Ganze, was Fiona auch schon meinte, irgendwie, wie steht es um, was ist die Haltung zu Plattformregulierung? Klar, das ist irgendwie nicht nur eine deutsche Sache, aber das ist ja auch was, was irgendwie Deutschland auf einer EU-Ebene beeinflussen kann oder sollte. Und wie gehen wir mit Plattform um? Wie gehen wir mit quasi diesem ganzen algorithmischen Kram auf Plattform um? Muss man damit anders umgehen als mit anderen Sachen, die eben nicht auf Plattformen, sondern in Verwaltungen stattfinden? Und das fand ich spannend. Und ich habe mich gefragt, ob es mit Absicht oder bewusst fehlt.
Die Innenansicht war tatsächlich, dass die Hoffnung ist, dass es aus einer gewissen Souveränität, die sich da erzeugt, ableiten würde, dass wenn wir es schafften, unsere eigenen Open-Source-Plattformen zu bauen, dass wir die Abhängigkeit zu den großen, kommerziellen Werbe getriebenen Plattformen deutlich reduzieren können und mit was Besserem am Start sind, was nicht als Ziel den Benutzer als Ware, sondern eher den Benutzer als Souverän darin betrachtet. Zur digitalen Gewalt, ja, stimm ich zu, hatten wir tatsächlich in der Kürze der Zeit einen blinden Fleck. Es ist schwierig, dort was Konstruktives zu formulieren. Aber ich denke, dass der konstruktive Ansatz wäre dort überhaupt Grundlagenforschung zu dem Thema, zu den Mechanismen, die zu digitaler Gewalt am Ende führen, aber auch zu allen anderen Netzwerkeffekten, die wir haben, inklusive dem Verbreiten von falschen Nachrichten, um zu digitaler Gewalt aufzustacheln, das gerne groß und breit überhaupt erst mal wissenschaftlich zu behandeln und dort einen Fokus drauf zu legen, dass man dort dann tatsächlich fundiert auch überhaupt mitreden kann und nicht einfach nur wettern und sagen, wir hätten gerne, dass der Benevolent Diktator Facebook oder Google dort jetzt dahergeht und sofort alles sperrt, was uns da nicht gefällt, sodass wir den Symptomen so schnell wie möglich hinterherdoktern und dabei den großen Plattformen noch mehr Werkzeuge in die Hand geben. Aber dort sinnvoll diskutieren zu können, braucht es glaube ich viel Forschung. Aber eine Forschung, in der wir auch sagen, dass wir den Ergebnissen am Ende auch ernsthaft zuhören und nicht einfach nur wieder Forschung, die wir am Ende dann wegheften und ein bisschen betreten nicken.
Ich glaube, an dieser Stelle auf jeden Fall auch noch mal lobenswerte Erwähnung von Anne Roth, die auch glaube ich auf Twitter als erstes darauf hingewiesen hatte, dass dieser Absatz fehlt und die glaube ich auch eine Person ist, die sich unglaublich viel damit beschäftigt und auch das Innenleben, glaube ich, davon kennt, was zu dem digitale Gewalt angeht und wahrscheinlich auch ein Forscherkette für einen konstruktiven Absatz. Und was Plattformregulierung betrifft, es ist ein unglaublich komplexes Thema. Aber ich glaube, deswegen ist es umso wichtiger, dass Leute mit facher Expertise, insbesondere technischer Expertise, da auch mit reingehen. Ich beschäftige mich jetzt im Rahmen eines aktuellen Jobs auch viel mit dem Thema und ich weiß aber, dass es da viele, viele Ansätze gibt oder Konzeptionen und Verständnis, so Konzeptionen davon, die in meinen Augen in die falsche Richtung gehen und auch von technischem, angenehmem Sachverstand zeugen. Und ich glaube, da fände ich es total gut, wenn der CCC oder andere Etät mit der nötigsten Expertise da auch mit reingehen in die Diskussion. Ihr müsst, glaube ich, nicht direkt die Antworten haben, aber zumindest damit einsteigen.
Na, wir geben gerne die Plattform auch wieder. Die Anne Roth hatte ja auch auf den Kongress genau zu dem Thema gesprochen. Und solange es dort erstmal die Sichtbeköfte, die Plattform gibt, wird es hoffentlich in dem Kontext auch die Kompetenz dann akkumuliert.
Aber ja, das muss also noch nachgearbeitet werden. Aber können wir jetzt noch den Blick in die Zukunft wagen?
Na, nachdem Fiona das so grandios noch dahinten verschoben hat, darf sie auch als erstes ihre Visionen ausrollen.
Ja, aber Fiona hat die Frage schon wieder vergessen.
Ja gut, so ist das halt mit der Struktur, nicht wahr? Es geht darum, die Regierung steht zum Anfang, in vier Jahren gibt es die nächste Wahl. Was ist das optimistisch, aber dabei noch realistisch seinste, positivste Szenario, was aus dem, was da gerade passiert, erwachsen kann? In welcher digitalen Gesellschaft leben wir dann? Vielleicht auch sogar ganz konkret wir als Personen?
Zwei Dinge, es ist jetzt nicht so übergreifend meta-beantwortet oder nur zum Teil. Zum einen gibt es formalisierte Prozesse und Formate, in denen die digitale Zivilgesellschaft, das digitale Ehrenamt einen Platz am Tisch bekommt und effektiv mitreden kann, nicht nur informiert wird, sondern echte Beteiligung erfährt, echte Transparenz, echte Mitbestimmung und deren Stimme einfach auch zählt und miteinbezogen wird in der Planung, in der Umsetzung von Vorhaben und sei es also auf allen Ebenen, in den Gesetzesverfahren, in der Vergabe von Aufträgen, in der Durchsicht von Anträgen und Verträgen, da sollte diese Expertise oder Community-Anbindung stattfinden oder es muss eine Struktur geschaffen werden, damit das effektiv möglich ist. Und zum anderen wünsche ich mir definitiv ein Aufbau von Förderstrukturen, die flexible, unkomplizierte, nachhaltige Förderung von Open Source ermöglicht. Und das muss in meinen Augen eine, ich glaube, dass eine Bundesstiftung dafür das beste Mittel der Wahl wäre, aber ich kenne mich mit Vergaberechtigungen auch nicht so gut aus, dass ich das mit Sicherheit sagen kann. Aber es braucht ein Förderinstrument, egal bei welchem Ministerium am Ende angesiedelt. Ich glaube, da gibt es verschiedene, die dafür in Frage kämen. Aber es muss vom Staat auch ein Schritt getan werden, um diese öffentliche Daseinsvorsorge zu gewährleisten. Und das bedeutet für mich nachhaltige Förderung von Open Source Infrastruktur.
Ich glaube, so eine sehr positive Vision, wo ich mich wirklich sehr freuen würde, ist, wenn wir in vier Jahren eine konsequente IT-Sicherheitspolitik hätten. Das heißt, wenn in vier Jahren alle verstanden haben, dass es eine echte Sicherheit ist, die sich quasi verteidigt und nicht auf Angriff geht, dass wir keine Diskussionen mehr über irgendwelche Hackbacks führen müssen, dass wir keine Diskussionen mehr über Staatstrojaner führen müssen, dass endlich mal diese unsicklichen Hackerparagrafen abgeschafft sind. Ich glaube, das ist machbar und ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn das passiert.
Tatsächlich.
Der alte Mann erhebt sich aus seinem Rollstuhl. Tatsächlich. Aus seinem Schaukelstuhl.
Wo klemmt das tatsächlich? Ich habe jetzt hier auch ausgedruckt, noch mal die Formulierungshilfe. Das sind irgendwie so 13 Seiten, in denen wir... Ja, ich wollte auch rascheln.
Warum druckt ihr denn alle Dinge aus? So geht das nicht mit der Zukunft. Wir reden über die Zukunft.
Wir sind das Problem.
Ich glaube, ich kann nicht die ganze Zeit hin und her klicken auf meinem Rechner. Ich würde gerne auch abstreichen, was ich schon hatte. Und tatsächlich ist ja viel von dem, was wir dort zusammengefasst haben, als aktuelle Kritikpunkte. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es einfach selbstverständlich ist, dass bei der Pflege von Infrastruktur, bei der Pflege von dem, was wir als Almende dieser ganzen Gesellschaft begreifen, dass dort Partikularinteressen viel deutlicher angezählt werden. Sei es irgendwie in so Dingen wie dem Glasfaserausbau überall hin. Alles, was tatsächlich die Zukunftsfähigkeit einer Gesellschaft betrifft, muss es verpflichtende Konsultationen mit so ziemlich allen Beteiligten geben, die dort in einer Generation groß genug sind, darunter zu leiden, wenn wir das jetzt vermurksen. Das heißt, es braucht tatsächlich für mich, für alles, was die Generationengerechtigkeit kaputt macht, im digitalen, aber auch in vielen anderen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen, braucht es für mich eine Plattform, in der Leute angehört werden, die Lust haben, Kompetenz mit beizutragen, die eben nicht nur finanziell getrieben ist, sondern aus einem tatsächlichen Wunsch, die Gesellschaft zu was Besserem zu machen. Und ich glaube, das hat sich an Zynismus eingeschlichen, sowohl Politikern gegenüber als auch von Politikern gegenüber Menschen, die ankommen und was verändern wollen. Und ich hätte mir einfach gewünscht, wenn dieser Zynismus aufhört und man tatsächlich in vier Jahren sagen kann, Experten, die mit ihrer Expertise...
Und Experten, oder?
Ja, Experten, die ankommen und dort beitragen wollen, dass die einfach mit offenen Armen entfangen werden. Und dabei ist dann eben Digitalisierung nur eins von vielen Aspekten, sondern dass Deutschland so im Großen und Ganzen auf seine Spezialexperten und Expertinnen in dem jeweiligen Thema hört.
Ihr gottverdammten Hippies, vielen Dank. Also in einer sicheren Open-Source-Beteiligungsgesellschaft würde ich auch gerne leben. Fiona, Anna, Erdgeist, vielen Dank, dass ihr heute im Chaosradio wart.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Eine Freude.
Viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich sehr. Ihr, liebe Hörerinnen, könnt das gerne noch mal durchlesen. Die Links dazu sind in der Show nur zur Sendung. Ich habe noch einen kleinen Nachtrag aus der letzten Sendung, wo wir über EID gesprochen haben. CK, der da war, hat noch einen ganz ausführlichen Artikel geschrieben über die Hintergründe von Blockchain, SSI und EID. Also wenn ihr diese Sendung gehört habt und dann noch mal genauer einsteigen wollt, gibt es da noch mal mehr Lesematerial. Ansonsten war es das für heute. Ich bin überrascht, dass ich nicht alles anzünden will, was meistens nach dem Ende einer Chaosradio Sendung der Fall ist, sondern ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es einen optimistischen Ausblick auf die Zukunft gibt. Mehr weiter würde ich mich, glaube ich, nicht herausragen. Mir bleibt deshalb nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.